vladimir putin has told the world that
russia is gearing up for a mass
vaccination program in october
the key word here is registered after
less than two months of human testing
on fewer than 100 people russian
researchers are actually behind several
other groups in the us and china
in terms of the science they've bent the
rules around approval
my initial reaction was it was probably
much ado about nothing we don't know
anything about this vaccine other than
the fact that vladimir putin got on the
airwaves and said
um this is going to be safe this is
going to be effective and one can only
interpret this as
a political stunt so what's missing
the most essential step in proving a
vaccine is safe
called phase three it's the last phase
of human trials and it usually involves
tens of thousands of people
so without that phase three data yet
i'm very concerned that they will be
using and releasing a vaccine that could
potentially be unsafe
could potentially be just ineffective
russia passed laws in april that would
allow companies working on vaccines to
bypass phase 3 trials
other countries have also changed or
accelerated the process by which
vaccines are made
china okayed a vaccine for military use
before publishing phase 3 trial results
and in the united states companies
funded by the operation warp speed
program are overlapping multiple phases
of clinical trials
still putin has confidently claimed to
have tested the russian vaccine
on his own family
there are currently more than 100
coronavirus vaccines in development
globally
researchers around the world are in a
race against time and each other
but developing any new vaccine typically
takes years
sometimes up to a decade so far only a
handful of groups in the u.s and uk have
entered phase 3.
their plans for deployment are as of now
a bit less ambitious than russia's
in the united states the trump
administration partnered with the
private sector to deliver
300 million doses by january 2021
and china has already offered an
experimental vaccine to employees of
state-run companies
the first country that proves it can
produce a safe and effective vaccine
stands to gain billions of dollars of
foreign investment
the vaccine will be marketed as sputnik
v a nod to the world's first satellite
sputnik 1
which the soviet union launched in 1957
escalating the 20-year space race with
the us
as many as 20 countries have already
expressed interest
perhaps putting sputnik v in the lead of
a biotech
cold war i hope it's not a cold war
certainly
uh this pandemic has been an equal
opportunity employer
it is this virus affects all nations all
ethnic backgrounds all religious groups
that
all we should all be brought together in
in this effort because all of us are at
risk
i think what vladimir putin has done is
political theater
russia's vaccine is being developed at
the gamalia institute in moscow
but in july american british and
canadian intelligence services
accused russian hackers of trying to
steal vaccine-related information from
researchers abroad
according to the new york times and
there have been widespread reports that
scientists injected themselves with the
prototype
and rushed through other tests to speed
up the development
so when people talk about this being a
race i say be careful what you wish for
because history tells us when you look
at the modern history of the us vaccine
program
the first vaccines out are usually uh
replaced within a year or two by better
vaccines
dr peter hotes has researched vaccines
for other coronaviruses for decades
and they are notoriously difficult he
says that the only way nations can solve
a pandemic
is by cooperating i think we have to get
away from this
business of cour you know of this
nationalism around vaccines uh
calling it the american vaccine or the
chinese vaccine or the british vaccine
it doesn't work that way historically
nations have come together
this concept of vaccine diplomacy how
you build vaccines
jointly between nations at the height of
the cold war and uh
and the two countries put aside their
ideologies to work together
they did that for polio and they wound
up doing that for this for the
freeze-dried smallpox
vaccine as well those studies that were
done in in
the then soviet union were um
instrumental in getting
uh savings or polio vaccine licensed in
the united states
and many russians never considered the
coronavirus to be a serious threat
so people didn't take it seriously in
the beginning
russian propaganda tried to present
karana virus is a part of some
great foreign conspiracy
against russia so even if the russian
vaccine
doesn't work putin has little to lose
politically from approving it
so he needed to enforce his
image like a saver uh
a defender like someone who uh
can uh make uh make russia great again
um if we are talking about people's life
yes it's a huge race but if we are
talking about
putting uh political and
informational risks i don't think
they're too high putin's announcement
could be a tactic to destabilize the
vaccine process in other countries
and potentially undermine trust in
vaccines in russia
and abroad tara smith studies vaccine
hesitancy at kent state university in
ohio
you have that ripple effect that you
know well if this one is not working or
if this one causes side effects well
what about
you know measles what about tetanus what
about pertussis
it can drive fear for those as well if
the russian vaccine
does prove to be safe and effective
manufacturing enough doses to share with
the world
would be a tremendous challenge if the
intention is to vaccinate
eight million people in the world
that's going to require something that's
never been done before
dr stanley plotkin is the godfather of
the rubella vaccine
one of the most common vaccines given to
infants he
says there's no plan in place for
worldwide collaboration
we'd have to suspend antitrust
laws and allow
collaboration between companies and the
companies would
would have to agree uh in some cases to
manufacture
somebody else's vaccines
the only way that will be possible is if
we
have some sort of agreement now
between companies whether brokered by
the wh so
or or somebody else
i don't see that happening yet the world
health organization has said it is
discussing the new covid19 vaccine
with russian health authorities we hope
that
some of these vaccines will prove to be
safe and efficient
and that you will be able to to get
doses
uh that will be then distributed in an
equal way
they have now about 14 vaccines that
they're moving forward with
the hard part comes as you note with
what happens next i mean
the hardest part of this is going to be
implementation and distribution of these
vaccines
russian officials confirmed that phase 3
trials for their vaccine
moved forward with 2 000 volunteers on
august 12th
one day after the announcement of the
vaccine's approval
mass production of the vaccine could
begin as soon as september
a month earlier than results are
expected from phase 3 trials for moderna
the u.s company
furthest along in the process russia was
approaching a million reported cases in
mid-august
putting it forth on the list of
countries with the most confirmed
infections in the world
more than 15 000 russians have died